hello party people welcome to another
episode of genius brain I am your host
Joe Jett Sakawa
and I'm your host David slow and we have
a very special person today that we
trained with in the morning we said why
don't you just come along eat some
dumplings and be on our show today Mick
and I was like that sounds like a
terrible idea but I'll do it anyway oh
and by the way if you guys have seen an
episode before this where there was a
constant mic touching it was because
Nick is a fidgety [ __ ] it was
Joe the whole time hey hey Dee Dee but I
know how to be on camera
Joe's Joe's a professional and I'm just
a [ __ ] a TD test right yep so here's a
10 brother - take the test though it's
only well it's kind of like so there's
there's 10 there's a questionnaire right
it's a it's a it's a [ __ ] I forgot the
name of the book but it's like ADHD the
the ADHD it's something positive like
yeah it's like it's like the advantage
ADHD advantage really positive right so
like basically the intro has this 10
part questionnaire and it's like you
know if you have 6 out of 10 you
probably have adult ATD or ADHD or
whatever oh [ __ ] I got 10 out of 10 damn
and you know what's interesting I posted
that thing and my friend I went to high
school with her and she's now a clinical
psychologist and her whole thing all she
does is diagnose children with a DD or
ADHD or whatever and then she was like
yeah she's like you know what come to
think of it like we had a class together
I was [ __ ] butt-ass wild like I
remember I had her sit on my lap we
would flirt like we will [ __ ] around so
much in class and in my teacher would
call my parents and tell them like I
think he needs special school oh yeah
you know it's it's interesting cuz I
have a friend right now who is kind of
so you know within I think immigrant
communities when they hear ADHD right or
autism or anything anything anything
their immediate response when somebody
who was Russian anxiety yeah
anything they go you don't have that
because my kids not stupid that's a
perception they don't understand it I
mean they gotta get rid of you that's
what they have to think yeah like a
hundred you just throw them over the
cliff raise your shield oh you can't get
the [ __ ] out of here my child is not a
defect yeah and I have a friend now and
for some reason it's it's very prevalent
with kids with autism where when a
professional says hey you might want to
take your kid to see if they have autism
yeah that person is not telling you that
your kids [ __ ] dumb they're saying
that if I hope people realize -
depending on the level of autism if you
catch it early yeah and actually do a
lot of behavioral therapy yeah that'll
help them adjust to it a lot if you
catch it yeah yeah that's what if used
to do
she should be behavioral therapists oh
that's awesome yeah so she knows you
knows what's up it could be like just
getting on a spectrum it could be like
you know there's different levels of
everything yeah um you know I I mean
like I don't think I'm as I'm much more
controlled now and then the older you
become you're supposed to be able to
kind of like control it better yeah and
all that stuff and I think clear and
with age is supposed to be it's supposed
to get better but I've met people that
I'm like oh my god you are [ __ ] out
of this world I think that's what people
felt about you when they met you the
first time I met that we were we were at
the San Diego Asian Film Festival and we
were watching his Jackie Chan film all
right and this will go crack me the [ __ ]
up cuz we were sitting in the theater
and a bunch of just Chinese letters
started coming out right and this will
no joke I just met this dude he goes the
[ __ ] I can't read that [ __ ] bro I was in
tears laughing and this lady next was
getting so mad she was can you tell your
friend to be quiet and I really know
that time I was like that's not my
friend I just bet if I don't know what
you're talking about but I would tears
laughing cuz it sounded so genuine yeah
so what do you think like the number one
thing that most people tell you is that
if you're 82 HD like symptoms like what
do people that notice that you do where
people are like dude you might have ADHD
we no one ever told me that really know
people tell me that all the time
I like the excessive you know okay so
most have a Papa in the book they say
that people with ADHD or 80b they tend
to gravitate toward athletics or
entrepreneurialism or like that's you
yeah but you do that's Lily it's
interesting because it's just that's
where they thrive I guess you're gonna
wake up tomorrow at 4:00 a.m. to go
running for a karate all day karate camp
right yeah tomorrow yeah all day yeah
and I wish I found it earlier in life
because it's helped me so [ __ ] much I
didn't start becoming off like really
athletic until I was 30 years old I
didn't start doing that stuff a lot [ __ ]
yeah dude it helped me so much like if I
had parents like Michael Phelps parents
right once he was diagnosed with ADHD
instead of putting him on pills they put
him in some type of athletic and now
looking Olympic you give it a [ __ ]
Olympics keep going man like when you
hit the zone you just you're just in
this place where you just oh this is my
first lap this is my first lap just my
first lap you're like a [ __ ] goldfish
yeah yeah and then that's why I think my
cardio is kind of good because like I
forget how tired I am
once I get to this stage I'm like
alright let's go again let's go again
let's go again I find any reason to stop
once I start breathing heavy dude your
first one to drop on the floor I'm like
I need at that point we can't like pick
you up we can't be like hey like you got
this once he drops on the floor it's
like the ultimate trump card it's like
alright well what the [ __ ] does that
have as I refuse this is I'm not gonna
be a fighter
what I realized too is that in if you do
have ADHD or whatever um we're we're
it's not that we're not able to focus we
can actually hyper focus for very long
periods of time on certain themes huh if
it is something that is extremely
stimulating mmm so like I mean a lot of
people experience phases of this like
when you go through the rabbit hole
online yeah right like you know that
feeling when you'd like researching
constantly and you just it's been four
hours yeah yeah that happens to me all
the [ __ ] time yeah every night that's
why I have to stay away from my phone at
night because I just have like this
obscure amount of knowledge about [ __ ]
that doesn't matter
you know because it's that rabbit hole
they go why do you know that I actually
don't know I think I might have read it
during the at night like a rabbit hole
[ __ ] yeah it's always like this random
obscure thing that this sparks my
interest and I go I have to know about
this Oh like the Rocky the Rocky yeah I
don't either [ __ ] do I know that I don't
know why I know that I don't know where
I read it right yeah and so it's just
it's just always this thing that always
sparks my interest and it just gets me
going through that rabbit hole and it
goes non [ __ ] stop and I didn't
realize how jittery and active I was
until I lost the weight oh yeah because
the fat was holding me down
it counteracted my ADHD and then now I'm
just I can't stop moving I'm super
wiggly and the mariel kind of hates it
yeah she's like I wish you were fat
again yeah remember those times when you
would just stay the [ __ ] stand you would
just sleep and then have a problem
expressing it but then you're just not
moving she's like chillin it's like
picking her nose she's like what you
doing just stay still as I can't do it
like I always tried a roundhouse kick
her in the stomach and she's like dude I
need you to be fatter you just are
feeding me more check again yeah well I
do want to take that test yeah I've had
a wonderful time I feel like a lot of
creative people have some I guess form
of it it's usually prevalent in
childhood and as you become older it the
signs or symptoms go away and you're
able to think clear and all that stuff
but in the most severe cases it's like
it gets crazier yeah
crazier as in like more intense you know
do people get medicated for 80 oh yeah
that's what adderall is for oh so if you
do have eighty D or ADHD what adderall's
supposed to do is help you focus
throughout the day but if you don't have
it you take it and you're focusing like
crazy on tasks that you don't even want
to but a lot of people used to study and
things a whole bunch of people I know
you said [ __ ] the study that supposed to
be meth isn't it it has the same
chemical like I guess structure as a
mass change a couple nitrogen so it's
basically meth yeah I did this shoot out
in Lancaster and I couldn't basically
you know three Red Bulls whatever
however many monsters I took wasn't
helping you
they started getting a crash so my buddy
who was a director he goes just take
this pill and I said what is it he goes
it's [ __ ] adderall and you know for
me I don't really like drugs but I had
to drive all drive all these people and
equipment back from Casa de la and I
haven't slept at all it's been like 24
hours yeah other hour I'm gonna take
this at all and see what happened so I
think it's a tall dude I [ __ ] missed
the exit by like four exits come I was
so so hyper focus just like this and
then when I went for somebody woke up
that where are we I looked around
oh [ __ ] I missed the exit by like four
or five miles yeah or some [ __ ] like
that
not four exits by four or five miles but
it was crazy how hyper folk me out a
little bit you know to the point where I
drove whatever like an hour and a half
two hours and I didn't realize I was
driving that long that's dangerous
that's [ __ ] Dave also Lancaster I
think is like the meth capital sent by
California it is who told me recently
that the reason why a lot of like crack
addicts or meth heads they they have a
bunch of sores on their faces because
that chemical secretes out their skin
and that's where they get it that's why
you see them well that's like thinking
at their skin and eating it or some [ __ ]
I don't know about that well I'm not
sure that's a fact but somebody told me
that you and your facts bro got a really
know where these sources come from
because I just read them too fast but I
heard that's why they you see them with
so many sores on their face because
they're scratching their skin because
that's where they can get like the like
a quick hit from it
I don't know but when you're like coming
we're going through withdrawal like
people tend to each a lot because that
probably makes more sense it's just kind
of like oh my god and it's intense in
here you know like when you eat it feels
it's soothing right it feels good or if
you like it kind of like give yourself a
little pain uh-huh that kind of removes
the the pain of withdrawal yes I think
it's intense like people really want
that crack or meth or whatever they're
going through and I think that's pretty
much why people scratch them that makes
sense yeah that makes a lot more sense
so you know that so there's like this
book of symptoms right like it's called
a DSM whatever but it's basically like
that's where you find a definition for
bipolar like oh yeah
diagnosed with yeah diagnosis right but
then in psychology so like that's what I
majored with um one of my professors
were like everyone has something
everyone has like so and then to to look
at this like as a disease or a defect or
something's wrong with you he's like
it's stupid it's so stupid because it's
not really an issue because everyone has
something in the book so what's so
that's like the biggest scam in the
world right so if every it's like it's
like it's almost like saying everyone
has this form of cancer
oh yeah it's kind of like well then that
means it's normal it's a spectrum right
right that means that if everyone has it
then doesn't that mean that it's normal
cuz everyone has it like show me a
person that doesn't have anything that's
that's the weird one you know that so if
you don't have any you know but it's
like when it becomes a problem is when
it takes over your life mmm because the
way we're approaching depression or or
any adversity now right pill poppin yeah
like people can't like people I was just
listening to this talk radio [ __ ] right
and they're saying like people can't
even deal with normal grief because
people have this idea that you have to
be happy 24/7 yeah so like if let's say
a death happens in your family right
like you're supposed to go through grief
you're supposed to go through depression
you're supposed to mourn that person cry
whatever but people become so much in
denial that they're sad
because they're supposed to be tougher
than that or there's they're supposed to
deal with it in a better way and they
start feeling bad or guilty that they're
even sad that someone died and then they
want the sadness to go away so they take
antidepressants or they take some
painkillers or they take something to
numb the pain instead of going through
the natural human experience of
depression or whatever but that's what I
would like from a lot of people I
remember back in the day so we did this
Jake a news article and there's just
girl named Jen in love that girl she's
super sweet but something would happen
something happened within her business
that she it didn't go well right it just
tanked and it made her sad and she says
I've been suffering from depression and
then my argument was well that's not
really depression because we know the
source for your sadness right it's not
something that's out of your control if
that event didn't happen you
be happy as [ __ ] if your business did
well yeah so because of that that's just
momentary sadness and and I said that it
was a little irresponsible to use it
that way I said I love the girl and
that's not what she meant but I said
that and the people got it looks like no
people suffer from depression I was like
no very true what I was saying is that
she openly stated that she was sad
because her business didn't do well yeah
so now we're dealing with somebody who's
happy just having trouble dealing with
adversity yes so it's it's there's a
huge gray area right now because this
word depression I think the two big
buzzwords
in psychology is like anxiety depression
right a lot of people talk about it but
anxiety I got anxiety I have crippling
anxiety I can't go out I don't want to
see people social anxiety this anxiety
right depression - like oh I I'm
suffering from depression like whatever
I think when it becomes clinical
depression is it sad when it round ruins
your life to the point where it's
crippling you can't leave the house and
you start becoming physically sick and
it could turn into something worse and
people actually go through that which is
legitimate legitimate like deep
depression right like and and the thing
is like everyone goes through depression
but it depends on how long you go
through it for and how bad it affects
your err severity frame yeah so like if
someone dies in your family I think like
crying every day for a couple weeks
straight is completely normal
but other some people see it as their
defected and I think when we say stuff
like oh you're not really going through
depression I think we're trying to
change that perspective because there's
a lot of like family members that would
be like stop being a [ __ ] stop being
weak stop doing this mm-hmm so I think a
lot of people are just kind of at this
point where they're fed up and they're
like no we just need to like accept that
depression exists but the definition I
think people don't understand what the
the the severe depression is versus like
a mild form of depression I get scared
of people sometimes using that as a
crutch to be the way that they are yeah
you're right so if they have negative
habits they can always lean back and say
well I'm suffering from depression so I
can't be blamed for this because I you
know people always see this online
all the times like well you're always
happy who the [ __ ] says I'm always happy
yeah yeah see that's that's they were
saying that that's also a cause of a lot
of people's depression is social media
they think that with the world around
them is happy which pressures them to
feel they should be happy too
yeah cuz that's social anxiety thing too
I don't like hanging out in big crowds
if you're an introvert action yeah yeah
if that's what social exact I guess I
have social anxiety too then cuz I
[ __ ] hate that [ __ ] when you
challenge yourself to to become social
or whatever right yeah like personally I
was invited out to go to a viewing yeah
I only knew one of the guys there I
didn't really give a [ __ ] about anybody
else and I was like dude just being in
this situation is gonna make me feel
really uncomfortable but I said you know
what dude just go out see this guy he's
a really nice to jam with anyways right
so I don't have crippling anxiety yeah
but I do understand I understand social
anxiety I get it yeah and I think
sometimes I get scared because I don't
want people to come at me and say well
now you're being very dismissive of how
I feel I'm not being dismissive I'm
saying that I understand it but now I
and they don't know that you're not
talking about the people with very
severe social anxiety like they've been
abused and and they're just afraid of
connecting with human beings that makes
sense right you're talking about the
more milder form oh your people can
actively try to preach the their
environment and do do different but then
now like any form of adversity they
treat that level of social anxiety
someone went through deep dark trauma
and they're just like in a crazy dark
place but it was like maybe they got
made fun of a little bit and now like
they don't want to go out and go to any
parties or anything so that's a lot
different from someone who was
constantly like beat up at school
remediate Lee bleeding and in there they
went through some PTSD trauma and that's
very different from someone who's teased
just a little bit that's why a lot of I
like a lot of people who talk about
trying to at least change your mind
state a lot so it's not as if when I
first did stand-up I was confident as
[ __ ] I remember the first time I just
end up [ __ ] hands shaking
Mike was shaking I was just trying to
blurt as many jokes as possible I still
how my stomach felt it felt like my
stomach was turning inside out yeah when
I was the first time I ever did stand-up
so is that anxiety probably I'm sure I
felt like I wanted to [ __ ] die yeah
but I said if this is something that I
want to do I have to go up again and
again and again until that [ __ ] goes
away it still doesn't to be honest with
you or if I do a very important stand-up
show where let's say like if I had
somebody came up to me and said you know
what I'm gonna give you a big special
and I want you to do it this is your one
chance to do it
you think if I did that right now I
wouldn't feel like I want to yak and
throw up yeah yeah just cuz I just end
up as I was 16 doesn't mean that I don't
get that feeling anymore yeah I think
it's because you have a very proactive
approach to life yeah right so like some
people they go you know despite the odds
I'm gonna change my environment I'm
gonna just even though I feel like [ __ ]
right now I don't want to be in [ __ ]
anymore
yeah but then there's also another group
of people where they don't feel like
they can control their destiny yeah so I
think the people that are in that world
their reality is more like hey man like
don't tell me I can control this I tried
I can't yeah but so there's difference
even in psychology there's different
schools of thought right there's the
holistic side where more like you don't
use pills but you use your own like
reinforcements so meaning like if you
have a very precocious yeah like but
even within cognitive behavioral therapy
some believe that you should do it along
with pharmaceuticals they're like
because you need you need the balance of
taking your pills and then you have your
treatment and then you you can go that
way but there's also another cab that's
like nah you don't need any pills all
you got to do is hit it straight forward
and try to like you know change your
your situation it seems like people's
ability to like cope with certain
situations is the big you know issue
right it's like some people have a
better ability to cope with a stressful
situation like you would experience and
then some people would be in that same
position and be like [ __ ] no I'm never
doing this again yeah because that is so
crippling to them but like I can't do it
but
to cope with a certain situation is a
lot easier for them not easier but
there's able to say okay they're able to
analyze what's happening and then move
forward with that yeah and it seems like
sometimes I get clients that are like
that to where their relationship with
like exercise or eating clean or
whatever is there just like they look at
it from a frame of dude I don't want to
[ __ ] do this sounds like the worst
thing ever
mhm and then they don't want to deal
with their ability to like eat healthy
or whatever that means to them I just I
think to that point to like I really
want people to understand I guess if
there was a takeaway yeah is that when
somebody says from their perspective
where they say hey like I go what you go
go through as well I can empathize but
I'm trying to get you to change your
mind your your your your position on it
yeah that's it nothing positive I don't
want you to think that that person's
being dismissive of how you feel right
but you have a choice it's difficult
because so here's the thing a lot of
people have different perspectives
obviously yes I'm so like the the
biggest the biggest problem here is we
all live in different realities like
reality the reality is what we believe
in is highly subjective yeah so I call
this system called bad right it's it's
ba-dee right and and so like B stands
for believe a is like awareness like
self-awareness and then D is like
direction or discipline right so you use
this in order to frame and change a
person's mind it all starts with belief
like if you don't believe that something
can be done then you can't even have a
conversation with them so if they some
people believe that hey I I'm diagnosed
with depression I'm gonna live with this
all my life this is this is I'm never
gonna it's always gonna be a part of who
I am right there's other people that
believe hey I am diagnosed with
depression but now I'm gonna figure out
how to change my situation and this
applies to anything like hey I'm poor
I'm gonna be like this all my life and
there's other people like I'm poor now
but I will not be because I'm gonna do
everything I can to get out of this yeah
so you got a first attack their belief
not attack in the way where you debate
them
I think a lot of it is like this is your
world right and when you want to show
people your world the more they feel
attacked the more they close up yeah
because what's happening is a lot of
people want to be comfortable and they
don't know that they're addicted to
their repetitive like reality people get
married to their circumstance a lot
right cuz it feels much better to to
have somebody go are you okay I'm like
that too
I'm that everyone is yeah but we don't
know we don't we don't know that it's
happened to and you get defensive when
somebody tells you that that's what
you're doing
you want to tell them you don't [ __ ]
know me because it's like telling
someone this it's like hey man I feel
sick I'm sick and then they're like no
you're not that's what they hear that's
what they hear is that you you're you
just you just gotta sleep you'll be
better and you're just like man I just
want to vent right sometimes I think you
gotta listen to what they're trying to
say and then once you you got it helped
them frame their world so then you you
changed your belief system and then you
got to change the way that they are
aware of them there's their own like
actions right cuz if you don't have
self-awareness
you can't look into yourself and start
changing what needs to be done or even
know that you have the power to change
your world and your reality and your
whole entire thing you you feel
defenseless especially if you're
depressed and you're just like like at
the bottom I think a lot of us do tend
to speak from a very combative point of
view right yeah so it's it's it's so
tense yeah yeah intense and it's very
hard to get up like so I had to learn
this specifically with Mariel yeah only
because how I grew up in my house things
were said very straightforward and it is
what it is right so I just I don't get
any feelings attached to things right so
a Mariel had a big issue with hearing
the word no from me I guess no was not
read much around because it she took it
as a personal attack yes right it's not
like you were denying her her
intelligence or anything but she fills
in the blanks and creates the story yeah
I think that's where the self-awareness
comes from she if she doesn't understand
that she's doing that she thinks you're
the problem yeah you're fighting her
you're mean to her you're the
because you're hurting my feelings and
it's coming from her point of view as
I'm very demeaning towards her it's like
yeah and there's a you know like we
mentioned this before where everybody
has a certain a lot of skeletons in
their closet that they don't even
realize it's there yeah so when if they
like for her what she found out is that
because I guess like how she grew up and
you know being in a Korean household
sometimes when Korean parents talk to
you they talk to you as if you're the
dumbest person we are and they talk to
us like we're [ __ ] dumb and so
sometimes like I guess when it comes
from somebody close to her and she heard
hear somebody go against what she's
saying well she doesn't hear is the word
no she heard she hears you're stupid
yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna speak for you
because you don't know what you're
talking about yeah and for me just
objectively I'm just saying oh no I
disagree with what you're saying yeah
and but think that's how it was in my
household right so I learned now to just
be a little more crafty with my words
and not outright say no right because I
have to understand you know people's
reality exactly you know so that empathy
has helped me out a lot and I'm still
struggling with it till this day yes
because it's just now she has to
understand that's not how I grew up so
help me yeah I mean you guys are very
vocal as a family you guys argue you
guys talk you guys deny each other you
debate so it's it's a different reality
yeah we because what makes our reality
is the first six years that we spend in
our household that's that's a we're just
a open program first six years of life
we're just learning everything of how a
family's supposed to be how the world is
supposed to be how people are supposed
to treat each other yeah none of this
stuff is like weird making a decision
we're just absorbing yeah so if someone
violates that program we go you're wrong
like a virus the virus has entered yeah
you want attack it this is this is the
real world you're [ __ ] it up you're
crazy
so that's that's what ends up happening
so then moving on to the D part that's
basically direction or discipline so
once you've got the belief end and then
you could believe that you could do
better
now you have the awareness like Mariel
is aware that she's taking no personally
yeah as a cell is a personal attack
right now she has a direction to change
that oh every time David says no
he's not insulting me yeah he's saying
no just to the thing I'm talking about
yeah and we can't have disputes we can
disagree he doesn't have to say yes to
everything I do
Yeah right but then you have to have the
discipline to follow that so the same I
guess the method to anything that you
want to change your program I just keep
it simple like that and I got to
remember that human beings are in
different stages yeah so a lot of people
are stuck because there's this whole
it's like a virus thoughts are viruses
sometimes so they spread right and then
that becomes the reality yeah so the
reality right now is everyone's anxious
everyone's depressed
everyone's this everyone's that right
everyone's in this shady pers like world
but in reality it's like dude we're
living way better than our grandparents
yeah it seems like everyone's trying to
one-up each other yeah like oh you're
depressed no like I'm so depressed like
do you know what I call it I call it the
oppression Olympics dude everybody's in
the oppression Olympiad big Oh Oh like
we I talked about this and this this is
like a cyclical topic but it's like for
example with like prejudice right they
oh well this is what my people went
through goes oh your people went to that
well guess what my people went through
this like dude what did you go through
anything personally no victim right now
like Jesse Jesse yeah yeah yeah like why
that like why is that even a thing like
why are you even expending energy on
pretending to get beat up to make a
statement it's cool it's okay it's the
Queen to do you know like you're looking
for drama or like or people are just so
fed up it's cool to take to get all the
sympathy points and I think it's
understandable for me when a teenager
does it right now because I think we all
went through that Vance but now for how
I see it is that face is lasting a
little too long it's going in from
teenager to your early 20s now into
these thirty year olds right it goes you
should have fixed that during your
figure out phase from like I say like
from 13 all the way to about like 20 to
23 minutes or just slowly figure it out
you know piece by piece yeah but now
because it's the norm to for you know
people want pity all the time it's like
you trying to say I'm running away from
home every day yeah that's like that's
what it is all the time it's like it
[ __ ] just do it then who gives
[ __ ] yes point eventually you're gonna
have to face your [ __ ] demon yeah you
know you can't keep running away from it
all the time and you just keep pointing
fingers at everybody else there's gonna
be the same place it sucks it's a
terrible place to be when when I go to
these college shows to people it is very
apparent that a lot of the times some of
these kids not all various I say a
decent amount just don't like
responsibility they don't want it they
don't wanna get their hands dirty yes
and they you know not just cause you
know I see adults now too I see people
in our millennial age yeah they they
hate they want everything but they don't
want all the [ __ ] that comes along with
it yeah and that's so unrealistic yeah
but it's also human nature yeah cuz it's
like so it's like government right like
for cents a Donna time you want the
government to take care of everything
for you but you don't want to be
involved in the government but we're a
democracy we're all supposed to be
involved yeah but we just want things to
run smoothly bout everything you know
like we want everything to be smooth
without us putting in work yeah and I
think that's I think that's normal but
it's unrealistic and it's gonna bite a
lot of people in the ass in the future
but I mean I feel like our parents have
been saying this to us like you're not
responsible their parents were probably
saying that [ __ ] to them and like genius
braid is brought to you by Skillshare
well everybody Skillshare is an online
learning community with thousands of
amazing classes covering dozens of
creative and entrepreneurial skills you
can take classes as everything
photography and creative writing to
design productivity add more so whether
you're returning to a longtime passion
project challenging yourself to get
outside your comfort zone or simply
exploring something new Skillshare has
classes for you and what's pretty
awesome is I've been clicking around on
the website and I saw one of my favorite
authors simon Sinek he wrote start with
why he has some videos on there so
what's awesome about Skillshare is they
have a lot of like professionals and
people that are experts in their field
that are teaching classes and I think
it's pretty awesome to continuously
learn even after school or even on the
side because when you brush up on your
skills and you keep developing and
growing you become mudda awesomes yeah
so joy the millions of students already
learning on Skillshare today with a
special offer just for
listeners get two months of Skillshare
for free two months my friends that's
why Skillshare is offering genius brain
listeners two months of unlimited access
to thousands of classes for free to sign
up go to Skillshare comm slash brain
again go to Skillshare comm slash brain
to start your two months now that
Skillshare dot-com slash brain like
Yammer me remember that hot topic that
came out it was I forgot what [ __ ]
news source said this but it was like
Millennials don't know how to do basic
[ __ ] learning how to sew but or whatever
right yeah and then they say some stuff
and and basically the the backlash
behind that was that well it's your
parents fault because they they're the
ones they we inherit a [ __ ] up world
yeah and it was like okay but my motto
argument to that is I could be on your
side and I do understand because I'm a
millennial too but every kid or parent
has had that same cyclical argument yeah
it's like well my parents should have
done this it's nobody's reinventing the
wheel here yeah right so you we're gonna
blame our parents and then our parents
blame their parents so it's not
something new yeah you know and so
they're treating it as if oh well your
parents taught you know their parents
didn't teach them [ __ ] either my parents
had to figure it out as long as they
were going my dad was a my grandpa
[ __ ] wasted all of his money yeah we
apparently my dad was pretty well-off my
grandpa invested his money into the
wrong people took all the money out my
dad lived in [ __ ] poverty yeah so
it's not like his dad did well either so
we're all just kind of learning as we're
going you know I just don't like that
thing where people are still looking to
blame somebody else for something
nowadays we don't really have an excuse
yeah like we kind of don't because the
information out exactly what that alone
is if you want a certain piece of
information it's out there but people
want it to be delivered in a certain way
which I understand but they want it to
be simplified they want it to be clean
concise they want it to be presented to
them immediately where it's digestible
yeah but that's just not the case and
you have to get your hands dirty and
kind of do some of that work yourself I
mean it's it's crazy just just to think
about our childhood like we had to get
information yet to go physically to a
library that was the only yes if you
either that or an adult tells you
something that's the only information
that you got you have any oh how hard
was get porn and she was so fat she was
so [ __ ] hard you lucky [ __ ] yeah
porn at the tip of your [ __ ] hands
now
you can do everything it could be a
millionaire just on your phone you can
learn how to build a business on Google
yeah you could [ __ ] open up a YouTube
page you could do whatever you could
record your videos on your phone you
could post like everything you could do
everything on your phone you can deposit
a check while you're watching your
favorite camera yes points to give to
the your favorite Shangri exactly as you
know Russia
she speaks no English but she doesn't
find your future wife or whatever you
could get began our relationship on your
phone you could get a booty call come
over like you could do everything and
you pay for it with Apple pay let me
tell you how difficult [ __ ] porn was
to get you know I remember this kid his
name was Shane in high school right his
black dude he used to sell anime porn
people burn CDs because he was the one
with like the DSL internet right that's
super fast and in the hole buddy had cuz
I was still on dial-up but he has a
newest album oh we got one kid and they
usually have like a laptop bag full of
[ __ ] CDs
he stole the [ __ ] weirdest anime porn
to all the other like the black kids
that love anime but they couldn't be
open about it is she a today's market
dude I learned about hentai through that
kid yeah oh what the [ __ ] is this it was
like weird tentacle [ __ ] like there was
a girl who's like so later it was a girl
who was like a ninja and then she got
caught by this monster started [ __ ]
her in the [ __ ] regular anime it's not
supposed to look like this yeah that's
dough yeah but people you should like
birds eat them when I was a kid I
remember there was that dude in the
neighborhood that was still a playboy
and he would sell his pages out the
Playboy bhasayate yeah and you'll be
like I look like each or some [ __ ] yeah
yeah that's expensive I can fold it up
and you plug and keep in your back
pocket books from nation overload man
but that's also why were bombarded with
negativity like we didn't we lived in a
bubble oh yeah we didn't we sure we went
through other day
changers that day didn't go through
today because kids are just home all day
now yeah but like we would like walk
around the streets get her ass [ __ ]
Jack be whatever physical danger it was
like the jungle right but then like now
it's a whole different kind of danger
yeah like they're just exposed to crazy
[ __ ] real early yeah some more it's so
much more readily available yeah it's
everywhere now yeah and it's accessible
you're you could talk to [ __ ] Joe
from Nebraska while he's calling you a
[ __ ] online yeah why dude what why is
this guy yeah talking [ __ ] to me he
should he should not be able to talk to
me at all and he's calling me a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
or having weird ears yeah like that we
had a we had our own version of [ __ ]
though we had [ __ ] ready to pick
which was crazy to say find a bit quite
a bit yeah yeah you just literally put
up a photo yourself and people rate you
yeah yeah I never did that [ __ ] cuz I
hired me what my rating would be yeah
and I refusing if people have no like
that
I [ __ ] refuse dude I was like listen I
know I'm ugly yeah tell me that I don't
need an actual star rating for it I
don't need to be official yeah I don't I
don't want paperwork behind how much you
think I'm ugly
what the [ __ ] anyways yeah I don't want
pros and cons on my picture that was
that that was [ __ ] xanga and shiz anga
dude that's so crazy I never had a
saying account yeah that was for him
[ __ ] emotional [ __ ] like me see
like we had logs and [ __ ] I had one just
cuz my my Indian friend his name is
Manik and he would he would Monaco yeah
yeah he would he would show me all the
the tight [ __ ] on MySpace yeah
xanga LimeWire that's why I swear he
would download all the porn and send it
to me yeah yeah and I'll be like and we
would go to his house and like watch
like dude I was so upset when I I was
downloading like [ __ ] boys to men and
also the random music through LimeWire
we get so many porn viruses yeah and I
couldn't even download porn because it
was so slow right cuz it would be videos
I can barely download an mp3 it took
like [ __ ] three hours download one
song and so my dad I remember he started
like he was he was kind of cool about it
but he was laughing at me he goes do you
watch a lot of porn again I when I
clicked your thing I saw this girl's
[ __ ] and [ __ ] like that and my mom was
like what are you doing I was like I
didn't even watch
horn duty was I was downloading the R&B
song I'm in love dude and then it sucks
because right excuse but they didn't
understand that it was a virus because
you would click on all these things and
it would just constantly pop up over and
over and over because I would watch porn
and my neighbor's house go smart you
know I can watch it I wish you never
know the the struggle of a 40-minute
download for one song yeah you know we
used to do to watch porn my buddy he
would I don't know wow he got these
recorded but on VHS he had a recorded
the real sex on HBO you remember those
softcore ones yeah but it was this and
it was like he would just have it on
cassette and we he play it and we'd sit
and we just watch it and be like man
this is that the spank bank moments just
yeah I'm not much later my friends would
start beating off yeah like it's your
dish like they would beat off right in
front of everybody's told me that in
would even elementary school there's a
kid that used to just whip out and just
rub the tip of his dick yeah you would
just beat off in front of everybody
that's a type move though yeah yeah she
would check off like this yeah yeah yeah
his take was a black belt like the top
of his head it was like yes flat yeah he
would put his dick right here his dick
head was popping out and he would write
rub his fingers like he rubbed it so
much as an adult his dick just was like
a Vienna sausage
it's a flathead screw we should just
look like a [ __ ] triple-a battery
that's like so flat on top what's going
on I don't know oh you know what we're
supposed to get into the actual topic oh
yeah this is better this is better to
talk about early porn moments your first
phone ergo okay first boner ever
actually I don't even remember my first
boner do you I do I do
how do you remember your first boner
because I'm having boners since like
little ever this is I think I was in a I
was in the second grade and I was in my
living room with my family it was movie
night and I was laying on my belly and
we watched Titanic
oh and then when she saw boom and I was
like what and I was like what's going on
just tell your mom no I just I knew
something I had to keep that to myself I
knew
I thought it was inherently I was like
you know what I'm gonna keep this quiet
and that was it it's you know it's funny
cuz we had a conversation on JK news
where everybody was talking about the
first time they jacked off and I I
couldn't remember it and I feel like
that's such a memorable moment you
should remember yours I saw I only
remembered it not too long ago it must
have been so bad that you just [ __ ]
like I remember you did I remember now
is because when I think I was a kid and
I woke up in the middle of the night and
I just started [ __ ] jacking off
that's tired right just cuz it was like
an urge that you had I remember when
something came out it felt weird kind of
hurt a little bit yes you're it's just I
guess you've never done it before and
it's like [ __ ] hurt yeah dick dry
heaves come nothing comes out but you're
just like well I don't like coming yeah
it hurt I was like oh yeah I pulled your
homies move and instead of doing this I
went damn plug in the car you know I was
like I thought I was peeing I was like
oh no I'm peeing everywhere like this is
bad and I just looked it's gonna be such
a weird moment when my [ __ ] kid jacks
off I'll tell you this the moment I find
out that my kids jacking off I'm gonna
take him decide I was like by the way
you do your own laundry now yeah all
right [ __ ] [ __ ] it's not gonna be
danger you want to hear like the most
this is probably one of my most
embarrassing stories and I just started
telling this to people when I was like I
think I wasn't like fourth or fifth
grade your boy was just going to work
your boy was gonna work and I think I
used to I said you know beat off in the
shower a lot smart move for whatever
reason I would always go my tippy-toes I
don't know why cuz it helps you come
easy yeah it does right Casey people I
said that to people people like what are
you doing is wrong with you and when you
flex your quad see this is when you flex
your quad it just for whatever reason I
don't know there's people that could
like confirm this but anyway so I
confirm ok perfect that's all I need to
hear so I would always do in the shower
and then I started getting like cramps
and my calves because your boy was
dehydrated [ __ ] busting in your car
so one time I got a limp right oh and I
was like walking around the house so
where my room was was right next the
kitchen and I would it was a short
little walk my dad was in the living
room which is probably like 20 feet down
and this dude his back is facing me and
he's four washed facing the TV
here's my door open he goes hey Nick and
I go yeah what's up he goes you got to
stop masturbating so much and I was like
what no I'm a cup of water because your
boy was parched I ran back in my room
and I closed the door and I was like
yeah that's because you were screams you
were doing it the [ __ ] walls aren't
soundproof right your father's a sound
engineer I know what masturbating sounds
like it sounds like you're making mochi
in there and I'm like I don't know
what's giving it away I don't get you
like tell you he's like do you [ __ ] it
come really fast yeah because we're a
fourth grade or fifth grade or whatever
like you think you're the smartest
person levar you think you're super
stout don't ya
like all your dad clean look you in the
eye cuz they're so ashamed weird jagged
I'm just like I just see him from the
back like just like hey you just gotta
stop jacking off do you say hey come
master 3000 ease up on your dick a
little bit please your foreskin oh yeah
hilarious yo so people don't know that
when you go on your tip and you flex you
could come way faster yeah for so when I
used to get my dick shower I gotta try
that [ __ ] yeah well you had my dick side
of the shower by a previous girlfriend
tie it she didn't understand cuz I guess
like when she would like suck dick
before
nobody would ever just like stand I kind
of like flex it they would just kind of
let it happen cuz they want to get their
dick sucked a lot longer but for me just
like yeah because in the shower I would
get dizzy yeah so bad that you're on
your knees right now yeah so I'm like
I'm trying to come as fast as possible
and once that come into your face and
then the [ __ ] water happens in the
hot water it coagulates I don't want
that [ __ ] I don't want to smell your own
yeah so bleach in the shower come on now
I want to extend on my tip of flexpay
she's like this girl yeah and who's
trying to charge up with this [ __ ] TV
talk
that's why david has such nice quads too
because he has such nice quad
development because he's just so used to
that isometric hold
yeah you should do your [ __ ] come
tutorials on your Instagram do that be
tired yes get that nice quantum calf
development make sure that when you jack
off in the shower flex them real tight
yeah Ian because that's the exercise
that most people do on a regular base
sex exercises exercises yes exercise
what a deem illegal or defying stories
ever heard of my life right would you
just come out hey son yeah stop jacking
off so much I can hear you it sounds
like drum line in there yeah cuz I know
you don't play drums guy that music
rhythm dammit build up in a [ __ ] EDM
song he's like where's the bass drop
what build up your Jack no matter Lee
did it I was I was jacking it I thing
goes first the fourth grade had a lot of
older friends you know you had to do it
because there they told me son sunscreen
that's they told me to use on sunscreen
yeah like what a slipperiness yeah I
guess I don't know I didn't I refrain
from jacking off for the longest time
because of the religious aspect because
the I felt so much guilt with it about
dude that when I was a Christian school
the number one question they would ask
is how like sex ed was like is it a sin
to masturbate because dude no no they
they they wrote the question on a piece
of paper a lot of actions so they pull
it out and it was Lee he was like ten
questions and questions same questions
same question checking ah yeah yeah yeah
it was insane
and we're all jacking up and then we
were all like looking at each other like
yeah cuz we all died here buying our
meats because when I did that the first
time I from then on I just remember was
a period where I just I felt so much
guilt for it I end up seeing some
[ __ ] songs and I got a friend we have
no but we had I better read from Genesis
although in Revelations
I felt like mad guilt for masturbating
and I remember feeling like [ __ ] so I
would try not to do it as much but there
was a certain point where I remember I
was like you know what I can't resist
this [ __ ] I'm just gonna just get rid of
it you probably would have been a
circular dude I would have gotten way
better grades if I just would have
masturbated way earlier yeah straight up
you know that pent up like a growl yeah
I got crazy because I felt so sinful
because of that [ __ ] yeah as soon as I
found out masturbation that became a
sport for me man yeah you were like
where can I do it oh yeah often can I
can I use what massagers like hey man I
just was the only thing I guess the
biggest reason why I like this so much
because after I would come I could focus
so much better like the only lasts so
long like I gotta do it again dude I
figured out how to cure cancer in three
seconds and I forgot it because I had to
come again yeah you're like [ __ ] yeah
it's like you know in a teens mind
that's when you think the most clear
right when you come that [ __ ] 30
second gel like oh my god oh [ __ ] I got
I got a check off again I can't wait for
the damn right don't have to come
anymore where the my sexual drive just
dissipates a lot more or just like yeah
it's definitely not as potent like when
you're younger though when you're like
in your little teens all you think about
is coming on everything yeah you just
you just want to come on anything and
everybody just rubbing up on like that
you would normally never work yeah
you're like trying to hump this or that
yeah when I was a kid my I remember one
of my brother's friends he he mentioned
the word come to me and I didn't know
what the [ __ ] I don't know what it was
yeah he goes I forgot what he said but
he said the word come and I was like
what's that and my brother stepdad he go
what the [ __ ] are you teaching my
brother get up yeah he's like your
brother doesn't know what [ __ ] is yet is
that late in the game though I think
like you don't learn that till your like
late middle school because you eat off
and when you're young it's just it's it
looks like saliva there's no white you
just call a busting a nut yeah that's
great now you would call that I just
didn't know what it was and then my
brother was like super entertained at
the dude he's like don't [ __ ] tell my
brother that type of [ __ ] now she's like
come sexually advanced
friends in fifth grade like the kids
already [ __ ] man that's so great yeah
they were like they had like they would
hang out and in like there's like three
one [ __ ] four of them [ __ ] and
like that's not even know what they're
doing yeah that was not the optic
ompletely I was just like yo you guys
are [ __ ] how much me jacking off and
then I seen the girl that they're
[ __ ] I'm just like yeah you know I I
never yeah I just I don't know I think I
I know in seventh and eighth grade kids
were [ __ ] for sure yeah you're sure
we're [ __ ] but by that time when I
went to junior high I was like I think
you know going to Christian school and
stuff and then no one was [ __ ] and
then when I went back to high school
people already pregnant and [ __ ] yeah
yeah no like damn ninth graders pregnant
man that's insane
can you imagine that [ __ ] now cuz I look
at high schoolers now like I'm like oh
my god we were babies yeah but they were
they were pregnant girls in school man I
was like what the [ __ ] well I used to
work at giant rocket summer I waited on
a table and there were these two it was
a two couples and they were maybe
freshmen so that was a fancy date for
them oh dude they were they're round and
they were both pregnant and I just was
like oh [ __ ] I was insane my um I so
there's a lot of Hmong people in
Sacramento and there was just so right
next to my parents store there's a Hmong
supermarket and there was a girl that
grew up with me around that area and I
remember she got pregnant when she was
14 when we were 14 and I was so shocked
cuz I didn't know her I thought wait I
thought she was my age why is she
pregnant
and that's when I started learning to
from like the Hmong homies they were
teaching me about that culture [ __ ]
they're like well like when you're young
already get married at 15 yeah yeah
she's she's actually already very sure
he actually has a husband yeah so she
had her kid when she's like 14 and 15
and then she ended up having like six or
seven kids and I guess there's like in
the Hmong culture there I'm not sure if
it's practice now but they're telling me
that they would actually they would do
this thing where they go into their
house and he kidnapped the girl yeah and
they would bring him over and that's how
you make them your bride and I'm not
sure if it's really practiced now or if
it is more of a formality but that's the
whole ritual because they were very
traditional Hmong like shamanism they
did all that stuff so that's how she
became a bride
came into the house at the night and
stole her away and that's like tradition
of what happens in yeah I mean when I
lived in a hmong village i was just mind
blowing because i was about 14 at the
time and there were like full-blown
families like husband and wife two kids
or whatever yeah they're like my age and
I'm just looking at them like well how
they're like adults yeah and then they
already dirty like so responsible with
shame and that's so crazy but that that
was the most of human like history yeah
yeah it's not that weird like if you
look at just overall just human history
that's normal look at Game of Thrones as
soon as a woman was on her period she's
ready to pop babies fly it's actually
the most healthiest - yeah yeah it's
that make sense that I guess like
biological biologically yeah but then
art we're just such an advanced societal
yeah but then you go different you go
across the world and the legal age for
like consensual sex or like marriage
whatever is like sixteen or yeah it's
all over the place yeah apparently I
heard Hawaii it's like a lot younger
than 18 oh really
I heard it's like 16 I don't know I
could be wrong but I heard this or I
just made it up right now
but definitely like historically
speaking they do we read all the stuff
like in like history books like just
from back in the day people get wed to
young young women yeah and even I guess
just from like a biological standpoint
when that's their optimal right that's
what like the eggs are the freshest
that's when you have like these kids
were super healthy is strongest all that
stuff damn that's so crazy yeah I
imagine you just lived in a time well we
do kind of I mean it's just weird to us
I think because especially in LA have
you noticed like people are still
getting married and popping out kids in
their early 20s in the Midwest like
small towns and whatever or especially
military because they get really good
benefits and [ __ ] so they get married
and pop out kids real quick but then you
know some people that like they have a
baby and you're like oh no you should
have not had a baby and that's what the
issue is I guess like the younger kids
cause they're too stupid cuz like when I
when I was in the hmong village right
and then I saw these like 14 to 16 year
old parents
they to me were so damn responsible then
like mature and there were just adults
already like they were treated like
adults they were running [ __ ] they were
working there were they were super
responsible I think like now but in our
society like what 14 year-olds are just
infants yeah stupid as [ __ ] but then
some people rise to the occasion right
like if they do have a baby like that's
the flip side of it like they have a
baby they're like oh this person became
way more responsible and it changed the
paradigm now imagine having the kid as a
14 year old like I just started my life
dude a 14 with the [ __ ] I was doing Oh
14 oh my god
I would raised a monster probably I
could barely imagine me having a kid now
yeah I still feel like a child yeah
right so you like just having a
conversation with like with my best
friend back at home he's just like do
you still sometimes like you're a kid I
was like dude I still feel like I'm a
child but I also think it's because you
have to teach them the rules and
structures of our society so if you
lived in a village right mmm what are
you what are you doing exactly yeah food
that's it go the social rules of that
village you know that's it
so you just love again as long as you
got [ __ ] lactating titties you're a
good mother you could [ __ ] feed the
baby yeah stuff right and then the baby
grows but helps out with the farm but
can catches some pigs or whatever that's
that's it we have seen it we don't but
in our society you need to teach them
about [ __ ] you know careers and
becoming successful and all this [ __ ]
and like oh you want them to be
intelligent so they can compete and also
be a you know worldly human being
there's just so many [ __ ] things to
teach you
you're a [ __ ] place yeah options and I
think that's what a lot of people yeah
and it's true because we do have a lot
of options yeah and it's either that
they're gonna be poor and living in a
fucked-up area and their life quality of
life is not as good as someone that's
rich and whatever like you you gotta
teach them the rules of that the social
structures the all this [ __ ] the laws or
whatever right like there's a lot of
[ __ ] we got to teach it's just so much
on our plate you know hmm not saying
that the village it is easier it's just
their values are different yeah you know
like you pop out kids family values
community everything is just local you
know they don't they don't got to deal
with too much
yeah because that's true cuz when I'm
thinking you know even prior for prior
to me wanting to really just tackle this
career in entertainment yeah cuz I
always wanted to do stand-up comedy when
I was younger but I still didn't
relinquish the thought because I grew up
in Sacramento Sacramento is not a big
light a lot of people don't go in an
entertainment within Sacramento they'll
move to LA yeah and so for me that
thought of moving to LA didn't pop in my
head until I started doing YouTube yeah
but prior to that I was just thinking
yeah I'm just gonna get married
white-picket-fence get married to this
chick that I know and that I just have
kids and just maybe do stand-up on the
side and I'd be happy and I didn't
really and then when I broke out of this
phase and I had bigger goals for myself
having kids scared the [ __ ] out of me
yeah
being in a relationship the [ __ ] out of
me I didn't want cuz your values and
options change man like what you're
capable of what you can do it's it's
just so different yeah and people are
like well why didn't you use like you
still don't want there's no I want it
but right now it's a very frightening
thought for me yeah like I I would well
I want to run the [ __ ] away from it yeah
and I it wasn't like that before all I
could think about was you know I want to
marry my it was my very first girlfriend
the time I want to marry this girl that
was me at 18 yeah yeah
isn't that crazy it's so insane now I'm
just like oh can I just like turn back
my age what's up man I'm not ready yet
yeah I mean definitely did we [ __ ]
went through this [ __ ] like nothing's
already like 57 minutes to an hour in
yeah man let me do the next one this was
a good conversation yeah it was super
good man yo yo that ends this episode of
the genius that [ __ ] was so [ __ ] fast
damn really
[ __ ] yeah she was another yeah it was an
hour yeah man well you guys uh you guys
enjoyed this beautiful talk we went from
psychology to yakking on Nick's Lorne
Nick's [ __ ] sick perversion of
jacking off at a very high rate to the
tow coming techniques guys check it out
just tag me tag me let me know how it
works out for you guys hashtag tippy-toe
coming and then also tag Nick the ear
the ear Toto coming style and you'll see
how fast if you guys need any tips or
tricks just hit DM me yeah me show me a
picture of your dick
yeah preferably December a lot of dick
pictures yeah yeah but like just yeah I
just do it anyway just grab it by the
base and smash it like a gopher game
yeah yeah you do anyways guys you got
two catches on stitches toons yep
Spotify we need those five stars we want
those comments below you want everybody
to be interactive I guess like for me
will be really dope is I want to hear
your guys astoria the first time you
ever jacked off oh yeah put that in the
comments below I want to know these
stories first time bring it up yeah you
know what we don't we don't want to hear
jackoff stories from just boys yeah from
the ladies to I mean not like children
boys all right yeah if you're [ __ ]
under 18 don't tell me those damn don't
tell us know something [ __ ] that's just
like a romantic novel for children don't
[ __ ] do that [ __ ] yeah yeah all right
guys go fish Nick what can they find you
you sack of [ __ ] you could find me Nick
the ear on Instagram or Nick the ear
calm that's right he's also a man who
does personal fitness personal training
soon to be nasib certified nessam CS yes
even better than nasa now baby you know
saying if ya hit him up dude let him
know he's partially the reason why I've
continued to gain weight if you guys
want any tips or just any nutrition
advice or whatever just hit up David and
not me I'll see you next time possible
goodbye yes